hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today i'm going to give you a
quick tutorial on how to use pubmed you
might be asking yourself what's pubmed
pubmed is a totally
free
free free free
database of
something like 30 million scientific
articles
that you can explore and so it is
maintained by the united states national
institute of health's national library
for medicine
and i'm going to show you how to use it
today and i love pubmed because it's the
reason i don't no longer have to use all
of these old
textbooks that i have access to because
now i can go straight to a very
up-to-date research database
so let's take a look at what
that looks like
here we go so this is pubmed
the actual url
is pubmed dot ncbi that's the national
center for biotechnology information dot
nlm that's that national library of
medicine and nih national institutes of
health dot gov now you can get to this
really easily
honestly if you just do a search like a
google search for pubmed it is right
there so it's going to be that top head
so here we are
now you can search pubmed this is going
to be any kind of research that has a
sort of a biological and most
importantly a medical focus
i'm actually going to search for
some things related to catridiomycosis
which is a disease in amphibians that i
studied when i was in graduate school
just to demonstrate that you can use
like normal boolean operators i'm going
to do a couple of fancy things i'm going
to add an asterisk adding an asterisk
just means that it's going to return any
searches that have something that starts
with ketrid that includes
cotridiomycosis the disease chitrid
which is kind of a name referring to the
fungus that causes it catridiomycota
which is the phylum the fungus is in so
i'm going to say i'm interested in any
of those things i also
want
uh papers that have the word
intraconazole which is an antifungal
drug but not
another
antimicrobial compound amphitericin
and so i'm going to
hit search there and look i've got 28
results of course if i had not been so
specific if i had just done that kit
with the asterisk then i've got 1800
results so let me go back to the
original search terms here
and the 28 results and i'm just going to
point out a few things
you can download this search you can
email this search
you can send it to some of these
programs if you use them
and as we go down if you look on the
left hand side you'll see a few things
you'll see that you can see kind of when
papers that meet the search criteria
have been published basically since
about 2008
which is when intracon is all started to
be used for this disease
going up to even 2020
if i wanted to search for only abstracts
or for example if i wanted to search
only things that have a free full text
available i could check that box right
there and you see we've gone from 28 to
14 and all of these are things that are
free articles you see those words right
there free article free article this
one's free pmc article
there are a few other things we can do
as well you know you can
try to limit your search based on like
if it's a clinical trial or a
meta-analysis or a randomized controlled
trial
or a review
um so for example i can see
that you know this up here is a review
this up here is a clinical trial let's
say that i only want to read review
articles then i can click that there as
well in this case there's only one
there's only one result it's that review
article
let's go ahead and take a look at what
other things we can see here
before we go back to the search page so
here i've got the article there's the
citation there's the authors there is
something called a pmid that's a
specific
number that belongs just to this
article in the pubmed database so if
somebody wants you to
if you want to share this article with
somebody you can say it's pmid and give
them that number and they should be able
to find
it right here we've got the abstract
which of course is just kind of a
summary of the article and if you keep
scrolling down pubmed will even suggest
similar articles so if this article is
something that you're interested in
these other similar articles might also
be worth your while
if you scroll even further down you can
see how many other articles have cited
this review that we're looking at up
here so this would be citing articles
and then there's also some like some
mesh terms if you're interested in that
and if we go back up one of my favorite
favorite things
about pubmed is that in addition to
giving you a link to where you can go to
get that free full text it also allows
you to favorite
uh
favorite articles you might want to
return to in the future and it helps
make citing so easy so what you can do
is you can click that cite button right
there
i can copy this
and then i can paste it into
you know a word document or a google doc
where it might be keeping a bibliography
you can download it if you have like a
citation manager that takes that kind of
download you can even change the format
so apa mla mlm ama these are all
different formats that you can
just easily copy and then paste wherever
you're collecting them
the link to the text is always kind of
in this upper right hand corner right
over next to the title so i'm going to
click on it this is going to open in a
new tab for us
and this is just where we can get this
review article direct from the publisher
and sometimes you'll have to kind of
look around on this page because it'll
look different for different articles
that are through different publishers
but as long as you have
limited the search to that free full
text that will only return articles that
you have
available for free so right here i can
see full text in the pdf format
and there we go now i have that full
text all of the whole paper all 10 pages
of it complete with the tables
and and their references and everything
that comes in this article
now i'm going to return to our original
search just to show you a few more
features i want to point out that you
can also get that pm id from the search
page
you can also get the citation from the
search page so again it's just a matter
of making sure you have the format that
you want
and clicking copy
and you've got the copied citation
now i am
going
to
simplify our search terms
a little bit
just to return some more results
and this way i can point out i've still
got free full text selected and so all
of these different ones are going to
give you access to a free full text so
for example i'm just choosing one at
random this one actually has
two different ways that you can go to
get that full text link
i'll just click on one of those two at
random and point out that right over
here again you can in this case see the
entire article
all the way down
or
you can click
and open the pdf
like that
so this right here is how you use
pubmed i'm going to
point out a couple more things
over here you can also you know where
where i had previously shown you how you
could limit it to a review you can also
limit it to something published in the
last year or the last five years or 10
years or choose a custom range there are
even additional filters if you're
looking for research specific to humans
you can check this box if you're looking
for
research specific to a certain age group
maybe you're interested in preschool
children you could check this box so
there are lots of different ways that
you can filter these results so let's
say that i am interested in
um anything that mentions
the kitrid kitrid fungus katridio
catridiomycosis
and nicomycin this being a different
antifungal drug that perhaps i'm
interested in i can click create alert
and
after i've made an account and there are
different ways that you can you can make
an account you can even log in with like
a google account
uh and and after you've made an account
once you click on that button create
alert
it will actually allow you
to basically sign up for email alerts
so that any time something that matches
your search term becomes available then
you can create that alert
and now i will show just one more thing
and that is a free service called pub
crawler
that's this pub crawler web service
right here and it is also a separate
free alerting service that scans daily
updates
to both the ncbi pubmed database and
also the genbank database
and this is where you know you do have
to create an account um it is free so
you just log in
and
then you can set up alerts so that you
can have pub crawler do that searching
for you which i think is a great idea
when i was in graduate school i had
five or six different searches and pub
crawler the very first time you do it it
will return you know 600 hits 800 hits a
thousand hits but after that
you'll get these emailed daily updates
with any new articles that were coming
out so i was always knowing what was the
latest thing coming out in my field and
it helped me really keep on top of
things with my research
so that is it today with my tutorial of
pubmed
uh thanks for watching biology professor
and let me know if this was helpful and
if you have any other questions about
how to use pubmed and happy researching
bye